[Music]
recently
a study was published in the journal of
social and personal relationships
oh tell me the detail for that one and
it examined
the ties to relatives neighbors and
friends
among us adults and revealed
that single individuals are more likely
to stay in touch with
provide help to and receive help from
parents siblings neighbors and friends
then the married you know why it's
because
we ain't got [ __ ] to do right mm-hmm you
guys have the time these people
are so busy because they got a family to
run yeah
and they're tired right if you need help
from me
just hold these people oh these people i
mean it makes sense
kind of this you guys are practically
married you live together
and you too i yeah i could pick people
up at the airport
how about that yeah no literally if
people want to hit me up
and hang out now i'm like bro you gotta
tell me like two weeks ahead of time man
you have to schedule it yeah you gotta
schedule it even even trying to hang out
with my friends because all my friends
are like
booed up now like my my close homies
they all like either living with their
chicks or they're basically married
so now i'm like if i want to see the
homies i'm like yo
in two weeks are you guys available for
us to all get dinner and we gotta like
schedule it out
and you got like an hour and a half
window and you gotta go back after that
sure yeah
no facts though right as opposed to when
i was living alone
i mean even when i was doing my long
distance [ __ ] when i was living alone
and someone was like
yo what you doing let's get something to
eat i'm like all right cool
yes that's what i okay like for me
being alone again like single again all
this stuff right
that is what blew my mind because i was
like oh my god we can just marinate
and then i always i had this feeling of
like oh i got to get back or i got to do
this or like
there's some kind of responsibility or
like there's dogs taken care of or like
oh whatever whatever right but now i'm
just like
all right what do you want to do
whatever we want yeah
[ __ ] it you use drinks after this sure
yeah you want to stay an extra day
sure as an introvert i like the excuse
of like i can't
i can't hang out i have to go back home
i live vicariously through stories
you feel trapped no it's just there's a
ball in chain
no no like you just shackled he's afraid
no like you're in prison yeah blink
blink twice if you need help
i'm scared but yeah so they were the
researchers found
that single people
or actually that married people because
of the fact that they have each other
and they have their immediate families
they don't tend to stay connected
to outside like the community and so
single people
tend to be more active in the community
and with their
their friends and relatives and all that
so it all sucks
also you get tired that's why you get
tired
and you focus a lot of building in-house
i i think
yeah and you already have a designated
person
that you're building with which is
they're already a [ __ ] headache yeah
your child which is your dad baby
your partner and your baby but then when
you
have the choice of spending whatever
time as long as you want or not as much
that's different i think before
quarantine i still try to do
because i really enjoy community so i
still try to stay involved
so like every friday i would go visit
david so in the martial arts
like i still hung out with the martial
arts community i try to go shooting like
once a month so i have like the shooting
community
but most of the time monday through
friday it's the like your own family
community yeah
now with the quarantine it's it's hard
to do all those things
you know uh in this article they linked
a
tedx talk with social psychologist
bella de paolo that was filmed back in
2017
and her whole thing it's titled what no
one ever told you about people who are
single
and so she says that she's been single
her entire life
and what a loser what a lonely little
[ __ ]
just kidding no it's actually really
funny if you watch it because then every
time they pan to the audience they're
just like
i hate you yeah yeah so pretty much
she's saying
in this whole talk that no one ever
explore like the media or whatever
as a society we never explore the option
of being happy as a single person
being independent like everyone in media
and society
everyone's just focused on i need to
find my other i blame disney
i need to find someone to spend my life
with like no one ever
thinks that they can spend their life
with themselves yeah which is which is
silly
do you think so i do think it's i do
think so i well i think it's silly that
there's so much emphasis on you're not
happy until you find that other person
i think it's so complicated yeah i think
it's silly to assume that everyone wants
the same destination
yes it's like just let everyone do
whatever the [ __ ] they want well
interestingly for her she says like
she's always
her whole life have have dealt with
people always questioning her lifestyle
choice
and trying to like hook her up with
someone and she's just like i just don't
want a relationship you want to date my
dog
i do happy being alone and then she also
threw in statistics and
it showed that when they studied people
like people who were single
versus when they got married like what
when they would project
their happiness like where it would be
single people would project in college
they would project that by the time they
get married their happiness
shoots up but it's the opposite what
ends up happening
is by the time like around the wedding
time like before and after it goes up a
little bit
but then overall it ends up being about
the same or less than happy
than when they were single and then so
she was just
entertaining the this whole like
statistics and idea of like you know
we don't all have to strive to be in a
marriage like
people who and then 50 of marriages into
divorces
and then uh 70 over 75
or something like that of like
subsequent marriages after that
end in divorce yeah multiple marriages
yeah oh wow
their marriage 75 of those end and
they're just really good at divorce yep
people are more skilled at divorce than
marriage
right or even being single you know just
focusing on themselves and being
independent and not necessarily needing
to have a significant i mean i think
divorce rates are so high
because of that right it's because
there's such a
emphasis on like you need to find that
person you need to get married and be
happy
yeah so people feel that pressure like
they almost they end up like settling
just because they feel like there's like
a time limit on it so then you
settle with somebody you're not really
happy with or whatever and then that's
why then you're like you're not happy
yeah
you know and then there's the other
school of thought where people are like
well i need to find my better half
my significant other so that i can so
it's like one and one
uh and now we're just we it's like a
half and a half and now we come become
one where it should really be like
i'm one he's one and now we're three
because i'm myself and then i'm like
with him yes bella was also talking
about factual facts
she was also talking about how single
people end up being
more well-rounded people than married
people because like what you just said
people
end up splitting their tasks their
duties whatever like you take care of
the kids i'll take care of the kitchen
whatever it is
and but single people do it all
themselves so then they end up becoming
like more
well-rounded person and they also tend
to grow more as a person than married
people it sounds like this chick had to
defend herself
so much that she became a [ __ ]
researcher like you see
yeah i like being single but there's
people who say
being single is great but then they
really want a relationship and they're
just kind of saying that like
just to like defend themselves you know
when you start pulling up stats
yeah you feel like you're kind of over
she is right though about
um there is a negative like i never knew
this because i don't
think this way but i did start feeling
pressure
to like hurry up and get married like
everyone else and all that from
my own uh parents and just like our fans
because
somehow i think society does equate
marriage to hap
happiness or like being in all the
movies like
yeah happily ever after right it's
always pushing you in that direction
you're not responsible
right like kind of like yeah like it's a
duty like you have to do it right or
being
even in a relationship um and then being
single
like i guess post 30 then something
might be wrong with you or whatever
but um yeah i mean like one of my
friends darian he's uh
what 41 or 2 now and like
he balances life really amazing and he's
been single forever does he want to be
single
yeah yeah well i mean he um
he talks about like marriage and future
and all that stuff but for him i think
he's the kind of person that knows
himself really well
and knows what he wants and i think
that's where
most people's problems are including
what me is like i didn't i just kind of
went with the flow
so i didn't know like who like what kind
of partner i really wanted and what was
right for me
but for him like he's just like no i
like this lifestyle and i won't
budge because this is the lifestyle i
want to keep and then my partner
will complement this lifestyle yes
instead of me having to give up a
certain thing
to be with them and i was like oh that's
really interesting because i always
thought that you have to sacrifice a
piece of who you are
to balance with this other person but
then
um well that's how we saw our parents
our parents were
constantly sacrificed and so we thought
okay well that's what we're supposed to
do
i think it's like it's like the even
though it sounds super cliche it's like
that whole like you gotta love yourself
before you can truly love somebody else
but it's totally true yeah
because if not right you got like two
people who feel like
i need someone else to feel complete
coming together
trying to fix each other pretty complete
exactly so yeah it's better to have like
two complete
ass yeah yeah there's one comment here
it's a in the
in her ted talk video they wrote in
reality the majority
majority of us get into relationships by
insecurity and chasing happiness outside
of us we let the person place or thing
dictate our happiness it ain't our fault
it's what society conditioned us to do
kind of messed up
yeah yeah yeah because people think
it's like instead of the journey like
they'll go oh
once i get married i'll be happy like
it's like i got it over with now i don't
have to worry about searching but i
think
i think the dating and searching and
meeting and knowing myself
is actually the journey is way more fun
than um maybe settling for the wrong
person right
so like just i don't know i think um
it's not i mean think about it right
like you spend the most of your
lives single or like dating
here and there like if you think about
in human history right like
you knock somebody up in a tribe or
whatever you guys get married or
whatever but
it's not the same rules that we have of
today
like today marriage and all these things
is like
you get together and then you're with
that one person but other cultures are
like
you just [ __ ] anybody or like you know i
mean like
the concept of it i think it's been ever
changing we don't have
just one way of doing things right right
this other comment
uh that i also liked was it says i
strongly believe that people
who feel like they have to be in a
relationship have unaddressed issues
from within
i related to that a lot because i felt
that that was the case
with me were you a serial relationship i
was i ever since
i was 16 years old up until today there
was
there's only been two months of me being
single oh yeah yeah you need to hoe it
up well you did
well i mean no you're already married
never mind i can't hold it up anymore
i'm married
um but no but like by understanding that
alone though and then like working on
myself casey working on himself
and like now we've gone to a place where
like we feel like our relationship's
really strong because now we've
we've grown ourselves to complement each
other versus
us always like clinging on to each other
for dependence
like we're just very codependent people
um but now it's
it's we're we've grown out of that and
i'm glad we have because man that [ __ ]
was rough but
yeah i think it's because of that
because like we just had unaddressed
issues from within
so facts that's what i try to look for
is when i see people and i'm like you
got issues
everyone's got issues literally
everybody
you